quand on veut jouer sortir mais huit
n'apprend un coq ou à utiliser nos mots
pour s'exprimer grâce à des boutons
poussoirs
mamans coquettes jouer magna au delà du
jeu c'est un véritable travail de
recherche que la doctorante mène avec
son border collie de 11 mois pour
l'instant il a après 34 mot
le plus utilisé ce sont des mots très
basique comment sortir manger ou caresse
jouer
explorez les capacités langagières des
chiens cela fait dix ans que les
scientifiques s'y emploie d'accord avec
toi tu vas d'autres choses
à ce jour coco réussir et associés
jusqu'à quatre mots dans l'ordre pour se
faire comprendre
machete jouer quotidiennement j'essaye
de lui apprendre des mots
basiques ou plus abstraits comme les
émotions la temporalité tout sa vie
puisse s'exprimer avec moi donc pour que
je puisse au mieux la comprendre
réclamer une activité désigner un jouet
les chiens les plus habiles pourrait
assimiler jusqu'à un millier de mots de
quoi considérablement enrichir leurs
interactions avec leurs maîtres à la
base et ils ont déjà la capacité langage
r
ils savent s'exprimer de leur propre
manière mais leurs mots on dirait leurs
gestes regarde tout ça ouais c'est très
limité tout de réussite temps de
réflexion bientôt tous les exercices de
coco seront passés au crible pour
alimenter la thèse de mes urines
[Musique]
sur les réseaux sociaux les prouesses de
coco le chien qui parle font déjà la
joie de près de quarante mille fans